better call Saul is one of the best
shows on TV right now
it's as entertaining as it is invented
it feels distinct even in the so-called
Golden Age of TV when I first heard that
Vince Gilligan and the crew were making
a Breaking Bad spinoff centered around a
unique but goofy side character I'll
admit I was skeptical but better call
Saul has turned out to be something
wonderful and amazing in its own right
and as the third season wraps up I want
to talk about why I think it's such a
special show examining specifically the
aspects of the show that set it apart
from most shows on television right now
this video is free of major plot
spoilers but I'll be using examples from
seasons 1 & 2
I want to start with a quick example of
the kind of visual storytelling that
makes me love better call Saul and the
pilot of the show Jimmy McGill our main
character is standing at an elevator and
we have no idea where and we get this
wide shot with a dented trashcan in the
foreground Jimmy looks at it so we know
it's important but we don't understand
the significance of it yet the scene
progresses and we find ourselves in this
huge fancy law firm where Jimmy seems to
know everybody they could have
introduced this location with an
establishing shot of Jimmy entering
through the front door but by
introducing the scene with Jimmy coming
up through the basement on the elevator
we've already contextually started to
associate frustration and possibly anger
with this location
even though Jimmy seems friendly with
everyone as the scene continues we get a
few minutes of dialogue that gives us
background about where we are and
Jimmy's relationship to these people
that's money for Chuck isn't that what
you wanted a measly 26 grand another
short scene updates us on a subplot from
the episode without using any dialogue
and then five minutes later just when we
started to forget about it
pay off
with a brilliant shot that pulls back as
an amazing reveal and with just a few
more shots they established the entire
context of a relationship we learned so
much about these two characters
relationship and history visually that
they can say almost nothing to each
other you just now I can't
and we already understand so much this
whole sequence uses visuals to establish
the fact that Jimmy has a history at
this place he's worked with these people
and he's experienced frustrations here
in the past but not a word of exposition
is needed probably the most immediately
noticeable thing about better call Saul
is the uniqueness of its look I could
spend an entire video talking about the
use of wide shots in this show building
upon some of the established visual
themes in Breaking Bad wide shots are
used to an amazing effect in most shows
and even in many movies these days why
shots often serve simply as an
establishing shot but better call Saul
probably more than any other show I've
seen uses them to their full potential
in addition to establishing places and
settings super wide shots communicate a
sense of Alumnus and they're used for
dramatic emphasis much like a close-up
is used in many shows randomly grab an
episode of any Network crime show and
Lal show off-the-shelf you often end up
with seams that consist of a wide
establishing shot of two or three people
talking followed by a series of
over-the-shoulder medium close-ups
better call saw a show where many of the
characters are lawyers and paralegals
could easily fall into this trap but
they keep the scenes grounded in the
world with these wide and ultra wide
shot but the use of wide angles while
the most obvious isn't the extent of
what makes the cinematography special
they'll often use longer takes dynamic
blocking and go
the extra mile with location work to
create some incredibly cinematic moments
better call saul has a slow deliberate
pacing that's really found on TV the
very first post title theme of the show
is a quiet awkward courtroom the cold
open before the title had almost no
dialogue and that's followed up with
this it's eight minutes from the start
of the show until you get a real audible
line of dialogue fed by a character on
the screen this is usually the time when
pilot episodes are trying to suck you in
with something exciting or intense even
Breaking Bad started off with more of a
bang a better call Saul establishes
itself from the start as being more
interested in the quieter slower
workings of the characters and the world
the dramas that are happening within
each episode are small compared to those
in many other shows or even compared to
Breaking Bad
better call Saul does an excellent job
of unfolding those smaller dramas in a
way that feels meaningful a smaller
story isn't less worthy of the screen it
just needs a different lens to view it
by better call Saul gives us that lens
by giving the characters the time and
the space they need to live breathe and
grow
the creators of the show don't tell us
to care about Jimmy McGill or to start
to sympathize with Mike Ehrmantraut hey
we're here with Wayne sculptor they
allow us to see them in action
good and bad and we can't help but
become endeared to them in the process
but it's not just slow we also get one
appropriate excellent use of montages to
move us through time quickly shows with
rich fully fleshed out characters are
more common in TV now but it's still
difficult to pull off better call saul
has very human characters that do things
that make sense for them to do not just
what the plot needs next Jimmy's
relationship with his brother Chuck is
an excellent example of this you look P
good I'm fine please just sit you're not
in trouble
while many viewers dislike Chuck and
tend to side with Jimmy as the
protagonist of the show when conflict
between them arises Chuck is treated
fairly sympathetically by the show I
understand that you have a great
affection for Jimmy how great many
people do but please open your eyes we
can understand his motivations and why
he feels the way he does when conflict
arises with his brother and this is true
to life in life when a rift forms
between two people it can often be hard
to place the blame on one of them in
particular instead there often tends to
be parts of their personalities or value
systems that are at odds and the blame
is often a matter of perspective the
show doesn't paint its characters in
black and white gives check my love
which it's hard to identify a real
villain for the show the show often lets
us see and consider both sides of an
issue
well Jim what just drive
similarly Kenan Jimmy's relationship is
one that is given very little exposition
we don't know much about their history
together or even their current status
but we don't need to because we're shown
as much as we need to know to care about
them yes mrs. Kettleman so good of you
to return actually I don't have mr.
McGill at the moment but I know he's
what is better call soul a drama a
comedy a crime show a courtroom drama a
thriller medic all saw often seems to
defy definition existing outside any
clears on relay Bowl it is what it needs
to be for any of an episode or story
beat some of the comedic scenes with
Jimmy and the brilliant silent
investigative scenes with Mike
Ehrmantraut feel like they could come
from two different kinds of shows but
the scenes never filled this man the
comedy never feels out of place and the
drama doesn't feel too somber it's a
balancing act propelled by logical
writing that serves the story instead of
the genre you never get the feeling that
they added plot elements to keep it a
crime show or a comedy I'm surprised
MacArthur better call Saul is in a very
unique position we know how it ends
before we even start the show sure we
don't know the details and there can and
will be some twists along the way but
from the very start the audience knows
what Jimmy will become they know who
Saul Goodman is from Breaking Bad but
even if they don't the cold-open
flash-forwards from the start of each
season reminds us from the very
beginning what the end game is for Jimmy
McGill Saul Goodman is an inevitable
future for giving the go hi I'm Saul
Goodman and I will do the fighting for
you no charge is too big for me when
legal forces have you
better call Saul how many shows
announced the outcome of the very title
most show titles are mere hint at the
premise but better call Saul is a
somatically purposeful show doesn't beat
around the bush I don't think that all
shows should be more upfront and direct
about their themes and where they're
going but the fact that better call Saul
does this set that firmly apart in a sea
of well produced TV it flirts with
fatalism in a way that we rarely
experience on the small screen in this
way it's the perfect spin-off and
development of Breaking Bad
it doesn't just happen in the same story
universe it cut from the same somatic
cloth better call Saul reverse engineers
Breaking Bad we're Breaking Bad was
about taking you on a journey of
learning to hate a character as they
become completely evil
better call Saul is about showing you
the past of someone we already know will
become a sleevee criminal and making us
feel sympathetic for that character by
showing us what made him become Saul
Goodman
better call Saul keeps the viewer in
suspense and I'm not talking about
edge-of-your-seat tension or fear that
someone is going to jump out from behind
a dumpster the writers are pulling you
along with a series of overlapping
questions and answers I think this is a
big way they're able to keep the show
interesting even though the biggest
dramatic question of the show has
already kind of been answered by moving
the audience's minds off of the question
of what happens to Jimmy in the end the
show lets them focus on how Jimmy gets
there the writers are comfortable with
you as a viewer being in the dark about
something for entire scenes or episodes
and even when the answer is revealed it
doesn't feel like they have to spell it
out for you
answers are slowly unraveled like the
true nature of chucks conditioned and it
creates an air of mystery that doesn't
exist even in many mystery and
crime-solving shows on TV today the
creator's truly understand show don't
tell and watching better call Saul feels
more like a discovery than being told a
story which for me is a cornerstone of a
great experience with TV or film
here's an example and this scene Chuck
shows Jimmy how to peel tape off his
wall so that the wood isn't damaged
Jimmy would rather rip it off quickly
but chuck is careful methodical and
precise highlighting the differences
between the two brothers nevertheless
Jimmy is willing to learn Chuck's method
and apply it gently left and right left
right I get it
wax on wax off a whole episode later we
get this scene and with no dialogue
so much is communicated about Jimmy's
unconscious desire to fit into his
brother's mold and his conscious
rebellion against that dire call Saul is
endlessly drawing me and making me think
what's going on inside that character's
head it's hard to rank better call Saul
among the many great TV shows right now
but I know it's one of the best it
consistently fresh interesting logical
and with great cinematography music rich
characters interesting themes and good
writing I find myself looking forward to
where the show will lead instead of as I
do with most shows just hoping the next
season isn't worse than the one before
TV is an incredible feat it's hard to
maintain quality for 40 to 60 or even
100 hours so when a team is able to pull
that off I can't help but celebrate it
[Music]
I'm Thomas flight this has been another
video for my series off the screen this
is a bit of a longer video so let me
know what you think in the comments
remember to subscribe if you want to see
more content like this and share the
video with a friend if you think they
might enjoy it I'm sorry it's been a
little bit longer getting this video to
you but I've got a lot of cool stuff
coming soon so stay tuned and I'll see
you again soon